are still in bed it seems like but
anyway we have two interesting talks
about two experts in the field of
epidemic modeling this morning session
and the first one is Greg who will talk
about Greg rampala who will talk about
survival models and connecting them to
epidemics one way or another
the floor is yours thank you thank you
so much this is a great honor to be here
and I really appreciate the invitation
and the opportunity to listen to some
excellent talks and
I also share some of the work that we've
done so I've been involved in various
aspects of of epidemic modeling but
today I would like to talk specifically
about one type of idea that's deeply
related to to estimation of parameters
and some kind of statistical approach
so coffee is a complicated and has been
you know a major uh
event that that we have looked at from
various angles
I will not really talk about covet there
is lots of people who can do this much
better than I can but I just want to
acknowledge that at least some of the
ideas that I will try to explain came as
a result of a necessity of making some
kind of conclusions about data that was
pouring in
various people making uh
various comments which sometimes didn't
make much sense and then it needed to be
a so so this was a kind of General
motivation so you know I'm a
mathematician but but for about a year I
was involved with this group at at in
the state of Ohio this was called the
the governor's special task force on
kovid and I was with along with with my
colleague from the math department who
was the real epidemiologist on there we
were basically in charge of trying to to
give Governors some ideas what's going
to happen
and I you know up until now I remember
the first day when they basically asked
us to run a model and tell them you know
how many cases are we going to see next
week this was in March
so you know we basically run some kind
of model that
the best one that we could put together
on a very short notice and then I
couldn't sleep the entire night because
you know I made a prediction I basically
said it's going to be X people and then
you know I knew and like many of my math
papers you know the people will verify
that that claim very quickly probably by
tomorrow
and uh
so it was it was very stressful
but it actually turned out that it was
not not bad and for about a year we were
involved deeply with some of the works
of of the Ohio Ohio actually did quite
well at least initially
up until the politics sort of started to
um raise its its head and it became you
know more of a political exercise in the
sense that there were lots of external
pressures on various types of policies
so this is kind of
a background for what I would like to
talk about but in principle I would like
to talk about some of the underlying
mathematical ideas that that came out of
some of these interactions
so the person up here this is the health
directors to shoot like the minister of
Health in Ohio and this is the governor
who is showing our model for some reason
he told his people to make him a
different picture so you know we had a
very nice one and then he came up with
this really ugly one that he was showing
at the press conference so anyway the
calculations were hours and for a while
basically until January 2021 we were
sort of involved with trying to to give
some ideas about what what might happen
what are the the the prognostics for
Ohio and the model that we used was a
network model
which has all sorts of additional
assumptions but again I will not talk
about it the reason that we're able to
build such a complicated model and
actually feed it data and estimate
parameters is because of these survival
models so I will talk about survival
models today in the context
so let me start with a very simple
example and in fact I will use the
simplest possible epidemic model and Sir
model throughout because it really
doesn't matter and it makes things
simpler I will look at the simplest
possible case meaning I will look at the
markovian system
yeah
so in the stochastic sir model in
general I have three types of molecules
as we all know and the idea is that I
will have two type of reactions if I
think about it from the point of view of
a chemical reaction system then I have
these s i r type of molecules and there
are two reactions one is the infection
and the other one is recovery and again
for Simplicity I am assuming law of mass
action so basically I'm assuming that
the the rate of these reactions are
driven by the the the appropriate
polynomials and and the numbers of
molecule
the basic reproduction number is in this
simple model typically defined as the
ratio of the constant
so
uh
let's take a look at this model more
closely this is one of the probably best
known stochastic model for epidemics
there is a standard markovian algorithm
for for estimating parameters there is a
standard classical statistical theory
for for writing out the the sort of
rather nicodem derivatives therefore the
the likelihood function and basically
fitting these these types of models
either in this setting or in more
General compartmental
but I would like to look at this model
from a different slightly different
perspective
and this model is what I would call an
ecological model in the sense that it
really looks at the Aggregates of these
different types of molecules okay
so in a sense you can think about
epidemic models or as as being sort of
divided into these two types the
ecological models and the agent base
agent base are useful for some purposes
ecological models are typically simplers
and potential they can be more easily
analyzed using statistical standard
statistical methods agent-based models
are typically difficult to calibrate and
you know in general these are typically
very heavily based on simulation
so the idea here that we had
was on the other hand maybe one more
comment agent-based models are useful in
some sense because they're really
allowing you to look at the level of an
individual and the individuals are
typically the ones that you will be able
to sample so you cannot sample typically
an average of a population that's
difficult
but you can sample individuals so you
would get these statistical samples that
somehow you would like to then be able
to to relate to some large computer
simulations it's generally difficult so
the idea here is that perhaps there is a
way of trying to build these agent-based
models in such a way that you could
borrow some of the strength from the
ecological problem so use ecological
model as a way of simplifying your
agent-based model and then use that to
to make some
inferences for instance or try to
understand the Dynamics of a particular
epidemic so my favorite construction as
I was telling
earlier
I think that this is my favorite
Construction in in all of the
stochastic epidemic models the silky
construction the silky construction is
really an alternative to a Gillespie
algorithm to the standard markovian way
of simulating a continuous time discrete
state-space Markov process in fact the
sulky construction does not require this
process to be markovian but for the sake
of Simplicity and in order to be able to
basically quickly skip over some some
things that I would like to talk about I
will assume for now that I'm just
looking at the Markov process
so the way in which you create the silky
construction is as follows you basically
start with a individual who is initially
susceptible and you
give that individual a random variable a
real realized random variable in this
case I will just for Simplicity I will
take it to be exponential with with rate
one
and I will supply that random variable
to every susceptible initially
susceptible individual
and then I will initially have
gets its own realization right right so
so these are IID variables explanation
right I will call it a threshold
and then basically I will look at the
number of infected individual at Time
Zero the I of T this is the number of
infected I will compute this quantity
we'll basically take the some kind of
scaled version of of beta which will
call it transmission rate let's say that
my population size is n so beta over n
and then I will take an integral over
the total number of infected individuals
okay so the number of infected
individuals over time this is like the
the amount of infection that I have in
my system
cumulative amount of infection so no
wonder this is called the cumulative
hazard
right so this is a cumulative Hazard
function the interesting thing is this
cumulative Hazard is random that's the
the feature of of the stochastic
epidemic mode
and that's also what makes it different
from some of the standard statistical
theory of survival analysis and
statistical
a theory typically you would assume that
your hazard function is not around
so this is a cumulative infectious
pressure and the idea of the cell Key
Construction the cracks of the silky
constructions now you will compare this
threshold with your uh with with your
cumulative infectious pressure so
basically you will look for a time at
which for a given individual with the
threshold q that threshold drops below
the cumulative answer
and at this time you will basically
switch this individual status from S2
and is the number of receptibles or n is
some scaling I can assume I will send it
to Infinity so you can you can think
about it as as yes the number of
susceptibles or the total number of the
popular total size of the population
it's it's a number that it's assumed to
be large and this basically means that
somehow overall infection rate is
controlled right so so this this beta
Over N is is meant to give you some
control over overall infection in the
entire population is it equivalent to
using the standard business rather than
mass action incidence
yeah I think so right that's right
that's exactly I think that's right but
you know the point here is that that you
know the overall infectiousness is data
it's not it doesn't depend on the size
of your population
really at that time it's it's not
adapted to Nature the N of T is just the
amount of affection
exactly now your cue shouldn't I start
my queue at the time I get infected
because otherwise no no no Q is not you
know Q doesn't depend on time right Q is
basically this this exponential random
variable and you are defining the time
of first entry in the world right so so
basically you are looking at the timing
at which this a n of T which is a
function of time will go above this
random thresh I I will show it in a
moment in an example
but
whenever now the one last thing about
the selfie construction which I will now
assume that these infected individuals
recover at some exponential According to
some exponential random variable then I
basically have the standard Markov model
but in fact in the the sort of obvious
selfie construction you don't need that
assumption but here I would make it so
basically the way that this works
is you have let's say that I have a
population that had only three
individuals in it q1 Q2 Q3 those would
be order statistics so I you know I
order these random quantities according
to the magnitude this the first the
second the third and I start basically
what this graph is doing it's basically
drawing that particular cumulative
function from time zero so basically I
start I have let's say initially only
one infected so then this basically
looks like T times beta Over N right so
this is just a linear function it runs
like this at some point it it reaches
the first Threshold at which point I
will have two people and I will change
the slope so you see that basically this
is a piecewise linear function with
different slope at some point people
will start recovering meaning that I
will change the number of infected so
then the slope will change at some point
I may run out of infected at which case
this will stabilize and this it will no
longer continue upward if there is any
cues left above the threshold those
would be the survivors
so it's a very simple very natural and
easy way of doing exactly what basically
generating a random variable from a
random cumulative hazard
so
the probability that
this random individual has not reached
yet the Infectious status is basically
the probability that that individual's
Threshold at time T was still above a n
of T given the history of the process
right from the very beginning
so because Q was exponential then I can
rewrite this probability so that
probability can be written as elegant
conditionally on on a and t this is e to
the negative a and t where a and t is
the cumulative Hazard so all this is
saying this is saying that that somehow
you know this e a and t is is just the
cumulative uh Hazard for that survival
function so another way of saying this
if I now will introduce this random
variable T which is standing for time
when individual gets infected
so I have a random individual with a
threshold queue and I'm interested in
the random time when this individual
switches from s to I so that's that's T
so that basically means that that t
conditional of a and t is basically
given by by that expression
um
oh the beta is in here right now
but beta is basically in you know
included into this end
so the circuit construction is basically
a way of realizing these random hearts
just to get the simplification
we will get to it but for now I'm just
taking break to be fixed you know this
this makes this easy
but it has to be uh
yeah you're right right because because
you would like to be able to to I mean
you know you could take a different
variable but then it it makes it more
complicated I mean that's the simplest
way to construct run composite
HT contains information on Queue doesn't
it no it does not because HG is awesome
so so this is the process that's
basically
yeah so so this is the history of the
entire process so accused for
independent was each others
yes
okay yes foods are independent because
they are they're ordered
to infect their order the their orders
but if I'm looking when you order them
you they don't if I'm looking at the
single queue I know it doesn't matter as
long as they're looking at the single
queue uh I I I think you know the only
thing that I need to know anyway so
let's move on so how can we make the
cell deconstruction simpler
a very simple obvious simplification is
as follows
uh we know from just the standard law of
large numbers for Markov processes that
if we scale our
total number of infected then we end up
with the quantity which is deterministic
and then
so basically the idea here is that I can
use this approximation I can take I the
random quantity I can divide it by n and
that you know by the the law of large
numbers
should at some point when n is large
approximate quantity which is
deterministic and in fact I exactly know
what this quantity is it's a piece of a
trajectory
of the appropriate
ode in this case since my model is
markovian then the limiting law will be
based on an ordinary differential
equation this is the macro sir model the
kind that that ABBA was talking about
yesterday
so
the idea here and again just to make
things a little bit simpler I am using
the scaling so the the you know I'm
scaling things in such a way that I can
use these types of initial conditions so
I scaled everything by by the size
so the idea here here is that I could
just take this selfie construction and
replace this random Hazard by this
limiting hazard
and then think about this in terms of
just the regular law of the just just
the regular survival model in which my
hazard would be no longer random but it
would follow this
this
limiting expression
so to make this maybe even a little bit
more
explicit I can rewrite this I can
partially solve the sir model
and I can write it like this so first of
all St itself can be written in terms of
that quantity but this I recognize as my
limiting approximation to the silky
construction so this is I will call it
calligraphic a t so this is exponential
of negative calligraphic a t then I have
this quantity Iota which can be
represented this way and then RT which
is again integral so it can be written
in terms of this telegraphic 18.
so
what do these things really tell
so they tell me the following that I can
think from at least intuitively from
from from from the
discussion that we have I can think
about St as a sort of survival function
it's a survival function because it
basically gives me a way of defining a
probability law by means of of that
limiting hazard
and as soon as I do this then I
basically see that for instance this
quantity now I can think about it kind
of as about density because if I put
this this raw term on the other side I
end up with negative integral s dot u e
to the negative this looks basically
like a convolution of two density
functions one of them is exponential the
other one would be the the density
associated with the survival function
so then this eye is basically a density
function which is a density of a random
variable which is a sum of two random
variables the first one would be given
by this St law and the second one is
exponential so what it is it basically
is just the sum of two variables the
first of them is telling you about the
timing of your infection the second one
is telling you how long you stay
infectious exponentially now okay so so
then that density would be the density
of recovery
okay and then this thing RT this is just
accumulated random Hazard so so
non-random Hazard at this point so in
fact if I go back and look at at the the
curves for the sir model I have this
interesting interpretation that I never
thought about really earlier that this
is kind of a survival function
this you can think of as a cumulative
Hazard this is r and this one is a
density meaning that this is the density
of infection
uh so
in fact that picture gives me a
probability law that sort of average
individual in infinite population should
fall
okay that's a very simple
I would say intuitive way of thinking
about it not clear whether it's useful
right but the blue card seems to go down
to zero is that no it doesn't I mean it
it stays because you know the the blue
curve is it's it's not a true survival
function right because you have some
survivors at the end
to me it looks like this particular
figure is
it
so you know so so this this will be a
survival function conditionally when
you're actually getting inside in
particular your radical properties if
you go to zero yes
but if you choose a beta a little bigger
than the blue cup I mean this is just a
regular sir yes so however the geometry
of this works
and this was just an example so I just
want to say I want to add one additional
component here
so all of this is in a natural way and I
would say quite nicely fitting this work
of of Gabriela Gomez and frailed
she was basically discussing frenulty
models and a couple of her recent papers
and this was one of the big things in in
some of the discussions about coven so I
did it here the salty Construction in a
very simple way but in fact I could
easily augment it by some additional
random environment so that the simple
way to do this would be I would assume
that I have some additional random
variable that's associated with every
threshold and I will just augment this
to make it exponential not with rate one
but with some rate q and Q would follow
some distribution
so then I can basically follow a very
similar argument conditionally on X I
can write the the the the adjusted cell
Key Construction and the cumulative
Hazard would look like this if I take
this to the Limit and if I use the again
the appropriate law of large numbers
I basically end up with something like
here which is a Frailty model
so the Frailty model is nice because it
gives you a way of incorporating very
simply heterogeneity in your population
so if your population is heterogeneous
in terms of the differences in in
susceptibility to infection which very
often you would be interested in
modeling then all you need to do is
really introduce this Frailty model and
put some kind of structure on on that
Frailty in order to be able to adjust
for it and it really doesn't really
change anything from from what I just
told you earlier the the whole idea
works
yeah so if you have Frailty then you
have this infinite system of equations
when at zero you have some Q of X when Q
of X is either a density or a mass
function you basically then can write St
in terms of of this Frailty and the
beautiful thing here I was showing it to
Christian yesterday is that this
expression simply says that your St is
now a Laplace transform
over frail to distribution evaluated at
this cumulative hazard
right so basically I have smoothed out
this this this St distribution with this
additional operator which looks like the
the LaPlace transformation
the second equation that I see
so so the idea is
the definition of
X
[Music]
so the distribution of X doesn't because
basically X is is uh this is all
conditional right so this is integrated
over over DX I'm assuming that this
integral exists
very original rate over X
but X wasn't that the friend this wasn't
their distribution so so there is a
frail to yes there is a Frailty and at
Time Zero s0 of X has that the initial
condition QX
so
um
TX these are the suspected distribution
of it no no no no no
because basically you know I'm only
assuming that at 0 S 0 let integral will
exist right as so so at s0 I won't have
this this QX so that's that's basically
how can you go back one slide
foreign
yeah so so Q X the frame of the
distribution is fixed it doesn't there's
no Dynamics on frail no that's fine but
so the Q X to that and if you now move
forward what's a QX so so so so Q X is
basically S 0 of X right s0 of x if I
had S 0 of X this would be expectation
of frail but now s is a decreasing
function it's continuous so so that that
integral exists uh but it's you know
it's it's it's it's it depends on time
right
so I should think
of
it
X is basically a heterogeneity in a way
of your of your initial population and
that heterogeneity propagates in this
list I is still the total number of
infections I understand that I just
don't understand how to get that
the
this is different I I was happy that
this is the formula for the for from
from the government state so that's I
was able to at least reconcile it so
what I really want to bring to your
attention is this so somehow this St the
way that I had it before
it uh it's it kind of it looks like this
this is e to the negative cumulative
Hazard once I introduce Frailty I am
basically taking this over here when I
am integrating I'm basically taking the
Laplace transform of the frail to
distribution
and now it turns out even more
interesting that if you take some of
these Frailty distributions to be
exponential family for instance then
then this can be evaluated and it gives
you a different differential equation
which are for instance if you take gamma
you get some you basically get back the
the JTB uh papers garments for them
anyway but that's really just a side
note here
I wanted to maybe try to explain a
little bit more about how this works and
more importantly I would like to also
understand a little better what is the
the error of these approximations right
I'm just making some approximation I'm
trying to make an intuitive argument
I would like to be able to measure how
much this really makes the difference
so the the this is related to this idea
of a transfer model of somehow DSA
framework
and this DSA framework is possibly
useful because it's a way now of
thinking about epidemics in terms of
transfer times as opposed to Counting
individuals in the in in an account
process
what does t s a stand for oh DSA this is
dynamical survival analysis so we wanted
to somehow excess of the dynamical
survival analysis basically means that
you are writing some kind of dynamical
system and you think about its Solutions
as defining probability law of certain
types that's that's all it means
we try to use different
acronyms but but this DSA sort of seemed
to have stuck and the point here is that
I am interested in transfer time so I
have this imaginary unit in infinite
population this unit could be of Time s
i and r and I'm interested in the
timings at which this unit moves from s
to I and then necessarily into r
and yes this probability that the unit
I called it t yeah so this is the time
at the at which the unit became I the
probability that this time of infection
is greater than T is basically my St so
this is uh this is the the formula that
I have shown before this is what I
called calligraphic a t and then this is
not really a survival function so in
order to make it a proper survival
function I have to adjust it at Infinity
but that's basically the same as saying
that you know I'm conditioning if I
condition this on the event that the
individual actually did get infected I
will get the proper survival
and this improper that so that
probability is computed from the the
epidemic size of course
so this is very simple and it basically
gives you this really super simple agent
based Evolution so you start with the
susceptible individual and that
individual has two choices either with
probability one minus how this
individual forever remains susceptible
is a Survivor or with probability tile
this individual can move into infection
and that infection will the timing of
that infection will follow the the
probability of this variable T and then
after exponential amount of time that
individual will move here
the sum of this time and this time is
what I call TR and this is basically
just the scaled version again both of
these quantities f and g they are
described in terms of the trajectories
of the initial
so I I can sort of think of it almost
like
Brownian particle from emotion we sort
of have said you have sort of this fluid
of the epidemic around you which you
monitor deterministically but my
individual trajectory becomes random in
this field right exactly because you can
think about proportion as being a
probability right so if you're asking a
question what is the the probability
that this individually random particle
ends up being I at some time T this is
basically the approximately
so that's a super simple idea oh God
another question this is really
interesting so I guess based on these
marginal laws you can basically simulate
an sir epidemic by just these individual
these independent sets of event times
and so just to give me a little
intuition
um if you were to have the realization
defined by these times how would it dip
like because you you did stick in the
like deterministic limit in here how
would that distribution look compared to
just like having stimulated Vehicles
yeah
in the large limit they will look
identical so basically it will it will
travel attempt so to recapture these
currents yes but like what what is the
like uh what's the cap like how does
that distribution approx like what is
what's lost so I will talk about it in a
moment that's that's actually the
which is this is probably a bad model at
the beginning
need some of the law of large numbers to
kick it which means you need very
effective people before you're allowed
to replace that's exactly right that's
right so so I am basically completely
neglecting the the stochasticity of the
of this initial infection this if this
would start from a single infection this
is a very bad moment so I am assuming
that there is a sizable number of
infected from the beginning and that's
basically what gives me the love working
so this is Europe after the flight you
know it was it was Ohio in in March or
April you know when you already knew
that there was a sizable number of in
fact so this is definitely that that's
thank you for that comment this is what
I should have said so that definitely so
so first of all why is this interesting
it turns out that you can do super
simple statistical analyzes of all the
so so all of a sudden think about
Frailty as an extension of this but you
know without Frailty you can just write
the statisticians call a likelihood
function based of independent random
variables so that's something that in
survival analysis people like to do we
understand it a lot we can use various
types of survival models like the the
the the
the proportional Hazard Etc we can
basically take all of the existing
knowledge and and results of survival
analysis and now stick it in here with
the understanding that this is an
approximate
so then the question is how good of an
approximation is it or or is it is it
just an interesting intuition so you
know this was one of the things that
that I wrote down as something that I
need to address during the pandemic and
then I didn't have time to look at this
so I did Solve IT partially but again
that solution is only for the simplest
case and then in general I I I need a
general theorem but at least I will tell
you what the intuitions are so
first of all uh what I need I need some
kind of Baseline so I will take the
selfie construction but from the
individual perspective and I will think
about it as a Baseline and then I will
compare it to my approximation and I
will try to measure how these two things
differ from each other
so the idea is that I can think of selki
as an agent-based model in the sense
that I can basically stick an individual
label on every one of the agents in my
silky construction as sir
I will have this this law an individual
agent is it you know the so the selfie
construction with individualized agents
it's still a Markov process right so I
can basically write it in terms of what
Etienne doesn't like which are these
these these these Markov processes with
uh with rescaled timings
um
so so so
maybe maybe quickly what these things
are so these will now be binary so I can
write my Markov process in terms of the
fate of the single molecule and the
standard way in which I can do this is
by means of one way in which I can do
this is by means of introducing these
rescaled poisson processes
so this question this this is a unit
poisson process which is on this
rescaled time and sis here are zeros or
one we just stopped at the first jump
right correct so it has to stop at first
jump because this is on the zero one
so as soon as you so you start let's say
that you are s-i so you start at one and
then you wait until the first jump once
the first jump happen this becomes a
zero so then you shut it the same here
if you start from uh I being zero then
you wait for the first jump you become a
one and then and then and then
and then eventually you have another
jump when you when you become an R why
should be I I read it in the first line
for the moment why should the individual
eye be infected just from those in the
sample that's what I wish no no no no
there so so these are all individuals
right so so this is the cumulative from
J course one to n plus n and n plus m is
your sample right no no no no this is
the entire population n plus m
so I'm assuming that I have you know n
plus M individuals in the population
there is no sample here this is this is
is
so so m is the the the the number of
original infections right I'm sorry you
know I
mean this is a stitched version of
several different talks when I use
different notations for different so
little again is still total population
by constant right it's not good right
it's total susceptible it's a population
so so the point here is that I basically
have a way using these these rescaled
Markov processes of basically
representing the cell Key Construction
from the point of view of a single
individual
yeah in terms of these indicator things
why do you divide beta by n and not by n
plus m
ah go that's you know it's I I could
have done it but n by n I'm here I'm so
what it means that I will have to
rescale Beta in order to recover that
this so I'm assuming that M and N are
the same one
so basically I have the following
representation
to be able to to explain this
so uh
so if you have questions we can we can
talk about it afterwards but but
basically I am looking at this s i which
basically means that I have an
individual who is uh susceptible
individual and I'm looking at the first
jump of of this process
now if I look at the DSA approximation
the one that I was talking about what am
I doing I'm basically replacing the rate
of infection with the deterministic
quantity right with with so so it's
basically instead of having a random
rate here I'm replacing this
i n with an iota
so I'm keeping the same Mark of process
I am just changing the rate from the
from the one that was random to the one
which is the terminus
so now I have basically representation
of these two processes
which I have on the same probability
space and I can I can compare them
so
I hope that this is obvious that that's
how it works right so and the other
thing which is also interesting here is
that then this reveals that this is a
very general method because all I am
doing is I am replacing a portion of of
some stochastic trajectory with the
deterministic approximation and I'm
looking at the process that that's a
result of
so you know this is applicable to
potential they're quite wide range of
different types of models here it's just
useful for SA
so I have and then that's the punch so
so so how do you do this
now we just you're in the standard
setting you basically write it up you
write the the the the because I am I'm
assuming that things are markovian here
I'm writing the ground wall inequality
I'm basically checking the the the the
the the the exponential inequality for
the poisson process and I basically
borrowed that information to to look at
the difference so basically at the end
of the day if I now have my S which is
the true model so I am counting the
number of individuals and my population
by time T who are still in s state
and if I look at the same quantity when
I'm looking this as star which is
obtained from the approximation then the
difference of these two it's basically
available so I have I got an exponential
inequality which I get because of the of
basically because of the of of the
poisson exponential bound so you know
the concentration and equality for the
poisson process
will give me here that the concentration
inequality of this so in your if you to
try to produce that performance that you
can probably have to use
yes so so we actually have a paper with
with my friend when we did it in in
generality and we used a different
concentration and equals but again here
for sir you don't get explanation
concentration under some conditions you
do so so you basically need uh some kind
of regularity condition on the process
and you need in general love of version
of the law of large numbers to hold
as soon as that's true
anyway yeah I mean this
this exponential inequality is true in
in this particular setting but I think
it holds for for for a much larger clubs
of of processes in general it's it's a
very silly
uh
trick that I'm using right because I'm
basically borrowing that that that that
concentration and equality from
something else and then I am just using
the
background wall of something like Ronald
the key thing is that you know I have
basically a very simple representation
in terms of the scale person process
so so this is useful because what it
tells you is that if you run this
simulation of mine which is an
approximation versus if you run the the
simulation based on just a selfie
construction I actually get convergence
quite quickly as long as as as my n is
is large enough that that difference in
probability will be small our n has to
be exponential in teams of this world
so so T is a finite Horizon here so so
again this is my problem with notation
this T now has nothing to do with the
random variable T that I was using it's
just
yeah right
so n has to be exponential but for both
L and T T is assumed to be finite time
provides you know true so so please have
C is yeah yeah
obviously so so you know these are large
fonts but you know the idea here is that
the pen could be in the order of
millions that's that's that's the idea
or at least hundreds of pounds
so this should work and it seemed like
you know an under under reasonable
conditions it did
so
what does it all mean sorry can I just
can you go back yes so uh if you think
but this capital T
end with S4
or storm or delete the most it will
probably not be very very far away
so
it's a good for you to perform
I don't see why it should be a problem
if you look sort of
10 years intern time or 100 years future
in time they will be more or less the
same right right you mean what should I
be able to follow the probability for
the shoot for orchid yes
it's not it's not very late
I mean very late
everything is over so absolutely I don't
know the fine mathematics no no you're
right I mean there is certainly again I
I haven't spent as much time as I
probably should this is mostly just just
to give an idea yeah the important the
final time estimates follow-up launch
numbers
are very small anyway yeah so so it
could be that that you can improve this
bound quite a bit by basically following
Constitution
like C of T divided by n which is
more practical and you could take
Infinity
so we've done a more subtle version of
this in in this paper which hopefully
will will come out this year at the
Journal of dynamical system so so we
have a more General in the same term we
we hopefully will be able to explain it
so for instance this works on sis models
it works in there it's other types
the point here is that it seems like you
do get convergence and there's
convergence is doing
and so what does it mean from the point
of view of surveillance for instance
so it appears that what you can do
you can build these these surveillance
networks which could operate as follows
you basically randomly select a number
of individuals these honeybee likes that
there are my sensors the little humans
that basically active sensors and you
basically follow the status of these
individuals you basically instead of
sampling the entire population
for the number of individuals you just
follow these selected ones over time
and you record the timing when these
individuals became infected
if you do this then it basically means
that you have a way of converting this
entire counting problem into the
survival problem when you're just
looking at the timing to infection
intuition being that if you see lots of
these individuals failing more or less
at the same time that means epidemic is
grown
when you would see these individuals you
know failing further and further apart
that means that your epidemic is
dissipated the beauty of this approach
is that you don't need to count
everybody in fact all you need is just a
statistical sample out of this large
population
because you are interested at the end in
in these epidemic parameters that are
not connected to to individuals so so
then once you have them estimated then
then you can convert it into some kind
of estimate for the entire population
but this at least you know in in many of
the applications that we have used in
Ohio this was a good way on a relatively
small samples to get an idea about
what's happening and this was also the
the one of the methods that we used at
the University so instead of looking at
the entire student body we would just
look at the random sample of 50 students
and see when they get infected
we were not allowed to use this as our
main source of information about covet
this was more like a useful hobby you
know so the University was testing all
the students but but nevertheless you
know even from from some of these back
on the envelope calculations it seems
that this is very efficient in terms of
resources and in terms of ability to
actually estimate parameters
uh so
all of this
is related with these these General pdes
that I don't really have time or really
intention to discuss but uh this is a
general pde model in which you basically
build these selfie constructions in in a
much more general setting and then you
have convergence to the PD I think this
is uh
this is a well-known result I think
several of you guys remember these these
might be your results from from from
some time ago this is just a general
version of the law of large enough
so what I did I took a very special form
of this beta function here which
basically makes it independent of of the
susceptible or infected individuals if I
make them just dependent on the
susceptible individuals I get the
Frailty models if I make it independent
I project I would just basically get the
usual ode
but
in general
out of these types of
pdes you can get that statistic I'm
sorry what kind of page is s so so you
have you have t is the time of the
system and S is the age of infection
this is kind of like in your model
so you have you have Perfection I mean
the first term is for susceptible the
first term is for susceptible that's
right affected by impeachment infection
so they are not but but the point is
that you're basically following this
this additional variable s you know for
everybody you can think about it as you
know once you get infected you
you
start Dynamics on on on on that variable
it's it's it's a you know again this is
just a slide to show you that there is a
more General structure I I didn't really
explain what these things are so the
point here is that that you can build
the sort of linear pde model when you
have in addition to the time of the the
the on on which this an sir model flows
you you also have some other variable
I'm astonished except that
differentiation by the actual time and
to fraction by the sort of time since it
affects you appear so symmetrics
you always have DT plus DS not the
button but there's a boundary there's a
boundary condition yes so this this is
explained in this paper that we just
published right I'll be happy to to talk
offline
the arguments of y s or white world
right
a lot of times each compartment
yeah that's right
so this s here is
that
just keep that yeah well so beta is the
the rate of infection so this is this is
the rate at which the the individuals
are getting infected so individual of
Yeah by by sometime s you know
individuals
again I'm sorry I did not mean to to
create confusion here this was mostly
meant to be a reminder that there is a
more general theory that that sort of
fits in what I said in a slightly
different manner
and what it does it basically creates
these more realistic potentially more
realistic ways in which we can think
about epidemics so for instance Without
Really changing the the overall behavior
of an sir model in terms of the number
of compartments we can see that that we
can now create this this more General
models in which you know instead of
having exponential time to infection and
exponential time to recovery we can
actually have
uh any type of of distribution that we
want to so for instance this was weibull
gamma and the idea here was that
we were attempting to make a prediction
based on these colored uh dots over time
so this is from the from from from the
simulation
and then you know the rest of the
epidemic was the black curve if we had
enough of the black curve we were able
to almost always very you know well
predict the the trajectory but when we
had only a little bit
then it seemed like the exponential the
markovian model was always
overpredicting it was shooting upwards
whereas these more realistic models were
sort of you know they were more
moderated in the in in the sense that
that they they they they they seemed to
get a little bit closer to what actually
was the uh the trajectory and we used
some non-markovian model but not from
the way bulgama family it was
let's handle
so the point here is that it seems like
by building these more extensive types
of selky constructions and using the the
the methodology of of that DSA to
estimate parameters you can actually
build predictors which are very
effective
and doing these human sensors is one way
in which you can attempt to understand
the Dynamics of your epidemic as it's
ongoing and you know I was very happy to
hear from my British colleagues that
they're basically using this idea in in
England now or in Great Britain because
they have contracted with the number of
households across the country
and they're checking periodically on
these households in terms of the numbers
of infections and that in fact they're
using this thing as sort of monitoring
system for the entire country
in terms of different types of symptoms
and different types of diseases but the
the key point is that this is the same
household over and over and over so
they're basically longitudinal following
these different households
for something what
that's right at least for a first period
of time that's right no so so you know
you do functional sampling base
that's that's exactly right so so I will
skip this so I just want to say one
thing these models are very flexible and
they're potentially usable in various
different circumstances we have most
recently used it on on some data from
from environmental sampling where the
idea was that we had some measurements
of water and we had some measurements of
zero prevalence and we wanted to see
basically what is the actual prevalence
so so these types of models can be
adjusted they can be adjusted
uh into you know adding you know
additional pieces to it and then they
can be used what this picture is meant
to show is that these models at least
you know in in the simple examples that
we have used seem to work you know this
was
an example when we estimated sort of the
prevalence of of of infection in one
County in Kentucky and this is the the
information from the Wastewater
so you can basically see that these two
curves kind of look similar they're you
know they're on the same
a picture but they're not related but
the point is that you have some kind of
dynamics of of these things that that
seem to be making sense
and this is you know another example
when we looked at tracking some of these
things with zero prevalence so but the
idea is that there's many potential
applications in different aspects of of
monitoring of these kinds of DSA methods
and what the DSA does it makes all of
this possible statistically
so I think uh this is all I wanted to
say
uh the really important aspects are here
so so these are my two wonderful
collaborators was your and then Evan you
guys know both of them they've been
involved in various stages of this and
certainly worked with me
on the the Ohio covet project
and I would like to thank NSF for
helping us thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much so if we're
interrupting you all the time I think
it's very nice to have these discussions
actually during the presentation so I
don't mind that at least I don't I'm not
the organizer are there more questions
yes Christian
so I have a question we had this
discussion whether we underestimate the
number of cases by a factor 10 hundred
or a thousand and do your methods can
you comment on that maybe your method
since you sort of have this nice picture
maybe you can tell us whether it's a
hundred or a thousand so I don't have
this picture here but because this is
just from the Wastewater but I have a
picture when I'm I think that in this
particular data stuff so so just a
little bit of background this was
from the 2021 in Kentucky in this one
big County around the city that's called
Louisville it's about 1 million people
they did an extensive testing of water
and also extensive testing of of zero
prevalence so they were basically
measuring how many people had covered
this was an a random sample and then
they compare it to water in that
particular analysis once we looked at
the water samples and once we looked at
our estimates I think there was about 40
percent difference in terms of what was
reported versus what was predicted by
Oman so you don't think it's a factor
100 as we were discussing no no I mean
for the word population so I don't know
how this would work for the world but at
least in in Jefferson County Kentucky
this was maybe half you know so so and
this was based on the water sample so
not just on the on on the counts based
on the models but it was really based on
the amount of virus that was floating in
in the sewer
yeah well that's that's great to see
actually the correlation between right
so we wrote like a really I think a
paper claiming that we have a wonderful
regression that that allows you to to
regress this you can use that as
protector next time to do some kind of
uh genomics well no not even genomics
surveillance to determine that that's
already an outbreak going on in the
population right even when the CDC is
not aware of it if I just monitoring
what's happening in the sewage system so
so this is a very nice feature of of
these types of models that you can
actually map it to something that's
measurable and um
your model your way of estimating also
seems to work like well that's that you
could use even if you don't have waste
water correct then you put estimate for
the whole U.S maybe one important Place
correct and again we would so so we have
done some of this we try to stay away
from these various competitions that
were run by by different people mostly
because we were so busy trying to fit
these models to Ohio
that we didn't do it in more generality
but it's possible when we compared our
methods of estimation and the results
from it to the official statistics from
that county in Kentucky that the
difference was about 40 and I have a
picture but not here so I I would need
to look for it essentially so I think in
general it's very hard question to from
the reported cases
to say anything about what fraction are
unreported I think it's an
identifiability issue right right Json
races and probably has comment on that
as well we discussed this briefly
yesterday
well that's not what my comment is about
but that's a fascinating question too so
first of all like this is a beautiful
talk I love it um quick question about
so you you have really nice results that
like you said allow you to simulate
essentially without really simulating
like pomp but when you fit data like
this um for instance like you have
access to hamiltonian mcmc and I know
that you had a really nice likelihood
expression and so you can take Radiance
with a potential family but when you
have data like this I guess is there
like an amount of missing data that your
method also helps you impute or do you
not deal with that do you not encounter
that so I don't so so the beautiful
thing about survival model is that I
actually don't have to worry so so if I
have data which says that you know I
have some kind of censoring or I have
interval censoring which I almost always
do I can incorporate this right because
I can just say I know what is the
probability that that individual got
infected between that time and that time
we have used this quite a bit for
instance when we're doing initially
survey equivalence of prisons in Mojave
when we had limited amount of testing of
prisoners but we were so basically we
had we had censoring right we knew that
that the infection must have occurred
earlier but we didn't know exactly when
but but you can put it into this
likelihood function that's the advantage
of using survival models so no so that's
basically also what I'm saying here so
this is kind of an alternative to
process reconstruction right right so
instead of like Computing the missing
data it just becomes converted to like
sensor times
that's awesome so you basically make it
simpler in this way
foreign
[Music]
overestimated the reported cases right
that's what happened or 40 our model
again I
which would be correct if you I think
you could always do it because let me
see if I have
a a way of oh okay so I'm showing the
picture because maybe
oh okay it was not a very important
um okay
so uh
idea was as follows this data was fitted
so I took the method that we had so this
method can be applied to various types
of data it can be applied to incidence
data which is typically what you would
observe from the epidemic curve it would
be applied to prevalence except that
most of the time you don't know what the
prevalence is
so you don't but you can apply it to
zero prevalence which is a little bit
better way of measuring the the past
infection so here we applied it to
incidence data in that county
this was the fit of the model and this
was the the the data the way that it was
given to us and then based on that we
have
calculated prevalence over time so we
you know from this incident rate we have
computed the the prevalence which was
this red curve over here and on top of
this we put the prevalence that we
calculated based on on our method and
based on the Zero prevalence sampling
that was done in the population
there were some problems with the zero
prevalence sampling because there was a
low response rate and there were some
biases so again this is not ideal but it
was definitely better than than what was
in terms of the the the overall picture
of of the community infection it was uh
I think a more reasonable approach and
we did it over time
so we had these samples
that were collecting like this this is a
number of positive tests and we did in
July October January and and I think
March
so this is kind of how how it looked
like in terms of the the number of
people and the percentage of positive
tests
these were all reasonably good tests in
the sense that they were
and that they had pretty high
sensitivity and specificity but we
adjusted this is not difficult to do
and then based on on these curves this
is this is this is zero prevalence So
based on these curves we computed
prevalence
which kind of looked like this and that
gave us also a way of comparing this
with the prevalence from the data that
was publicly there so if the red curve
is the data that was available from the
the Jefferson County public uh
Public Health site then that the red was
then the black one is the one that sort
of comes out of the the prevalence
estimates that we have completed so
forty percent difference yeah that's
it's it's it's a little bit more but but
so for a while it was more or less the
same
or very similar and then it diverted
quite a bit I think we um for this we
can continue discussion but uh it's time
for coffee and we reconvene at 11
o'clock if Joel Miller has arrived by
them otherwise it's a longer break well
yeah that's I need to mention because he
may not be here physically he may be
presented from his hotel room he's a
little under the weather so I'll try to
yeah so it's possible or we get Greg to
continue talking for another hour now
breaks
I'm not sure if you would like that but
but thank you very much for this
[Applause]